hey this is presh to Walker
we have a quarter circle and a square
inside the quarter Circle
two of the scores Corners are touching
radii of the quarter Circle the third
corner is on the circumference and the
fourth corner is in the interior and its
distance to its nearest corner of the
quarter circle is equal to two
from an adjacent quarter on the radius
the horizontal length to the corner of
the quarter Circle has a length that's
equal to five the question is what is
the side length of the square equal to
this was posted on Reddit ask math with
the title that this problem stumped the
entire math department
now in order to solve this you are
allowed to give an approximate value to
three decimal places you can use a
symbolic or numerical solver
the problem was created by at dare to
solve on Instagram and Twitter and I
think Fortaleza and Wally for the
suggestion
pause the video if you'd like to give
this problem a try and when you're ready
keep watching to learn how to solve this
problem
[Music]
this problem we will construct some
triangles
drop a perpendicular right here and say
this side length is equal to B then let
the other leg of this right triangle be
equal to a so then this length of 5 will
be equal to a and five minus a
this right triangle with legs of A and B
is exactly congruent to the right
triangle that's on the center of this
quarter Circle so this right triangle
will have legs of B and A now we'll
construct another congruent right
triangle by dropping a perpendicular
from the corner of the square right here
so this right triangle will have side
lengths that's equal to B and A
construct this radius of the quarter
Circle
now the radius of the quarter Circle
will be equal to B plus five so this
length will be equal to B plus five
so now we're pretty much ready to solve
the problem let the side length of the
square be equal to s
now in this right triangle we have a
plus b the quantity squared plus a
squared is equal to the square of B plus
five
in this right triangle here we have B
squared plus the square of 5 minus a is
equal to 2 squared which is equal to 4.
then in this right triangle here we have
a squared plus b squared is equal to S
squared
now you could work through these
equations you'll end up with a quartic
equation in a
you'll eventually solve it and you'll
need to get an approximate value for a
then you'll get an approximate value for
B and you can solve for an approximate
value of s
but since we can use a numerical solver
let's just plug these three equations
into Wolfram Alpha we get the following
real solutions but we want to make sure
that all of these lengths a b and s are
positive values we don't want any
negative values so we will eliminate the
first three possibilities and we are
left with the solution
s is approximately equal to
4.120 and that's the answer
thanks for making us one of the best
communities on YouTube see you next
episode of mind your decisions where we
solve The World's problems one video at
a time